what did you say your name was again
Barry Allen listy smoke hey youtubers is
Charlie welcome to my new show ask
emergency as you may have guessed this
is where I take your questions and
answer them about specific fandom topics
this video will be all about the flash
that we just saw an arrow as well as the
spin-off that's coming and what's going
to be happening with that show so this
is how these videos are gonna work I'll
basically collect your questions for
specific topics and then I'll choose one
or two videos to do per week based on
those so there might be like a Doctor
Who Christmas special ask emergency
there might be like a game of Thrones
ask emergency stuff like that I'll also
do bonus additions in case there's
anything that you guys really really
want to talk about so be sure to
subscribe to get everything so I picked
seven of you guys questions to answer
about the flash since we've had a lot of
questions and now we finally have a few
answers so first question comes from
Ricardo Rodriguez and he says I think
the producers are going with the flash
rebirth route with Barry so yes this is
correct they are going with the flash
Buber throughout this actually ties into
one of the Easter eggs that I put in my
arrow video from last night if you
remember someone came and killed Barry's
parents that look like a human tornado
so he was actually talking about
sabotage remember professor zoom was
actually behind that whole plot so zoom
will always be the big bad of any flash
story but there will be a lot of other
villains involved so that will obviously
carry over into the flash show as well
they're really gonna use that show to
deal with Barry getting his powers as
well as dealing with his mother's murder
question number two
so rates outta our ass why did they poke
on and Isabel all over a relationship
and they never go there again what was
up with the bar scene
so they kind of just implied that the
Oliver is of all things just a one-night
stand on the show and all of his mother
kind of dissed her at the bar saying
that Oliver was never really good judge
of character leading me to believe that
Oliver is actually gonna be betrayed by
Isabel at some point we don't know if
she is either working with hive or with
the League of Assassins or with brother
blood yet I have a lot of theories on
each of those that I've had some of my
past arrow videos question number three
shell or asks is the actor on arrow
going to be in the flash spinoff so
you're talking about Grant Gustin
yes he will be the flash in the flash
spinoff what they were gonna do
originally is an episode 20 of arrow
this year they're going to give him his
powers and it was gonna be like a
backdoor pilot but like I said in my
other arrow video
they basically liked the way it went so
much that they decided to just do a full
hour-long pilot
separately from arrow well either get to
see that pilot in the spring or we'll
get to see it at comic-con question
number four pink starburst 99 asks do
you think that the flash will overshadow
Oliver because he actually has powers
what makes Oliver better than Barry so
right now for all intensive purposes
Oliver is a fully-funded remember he's a
billionaire fully actualized hero he's
not at that Green Arrow level of persona
but remember Barry has no powers and
he's still coming out he's clumsy on his
feet he's a good scientist but there's a
lot of things that he has to do before
he becomes a superhero and the whole
first season of that flash show is gonna
deal with him learning to control his
abilities you can also think of it in
like a Batman Superman context so Batman
does not have any superpowers but he is
a billionaire and he is just as much of
a threat as Superman just because of his
wit so that's gonna kind of be the same
dynamic between arrow and the flash
question number five brace go asks what
was up with the mask Oliver's wearing in
the next episode this is just because he
says his identity has been compromised
so brother blood obviously the big
confrontation is coming in the next
episode learns his identity as well as
Barry Allen now so people are starting
to learn who he is they're able to see
him through that mask because he really
doesn't wear any kind of face covering
it's just the cowl so it's just him like
getting closer to that Green Arrow level
question number six Ivan Calderon asks
on Twitter what did you think of grants
performance so there are a lot of people
that commented on grants performance
saying that he was just a little too
clumsy but if you remember this is a pre
flash version of Barry Allen so in the
comic books most of the time when we've
seen Barry Allen he's already a
superhero so I think that grants
performance was totally authentic to the
origins of the character along with
being you know a little bit of his own
because obviously he's the one that has
to be on this show so he kinda has to
make the character his own - that being
said yes he is a little bit of a derp
but he's supposed to be question number
seven
salvadore Gutierrez asks who is your
favorite flash so this is interesting
because Barry Allen is actually always
been my favorite flash but for most of
the time when I was reading comic books
as they were being released Wally West
was the flash I'm a bit of a purist so
for instance like Hal Jordan is my
favorite Green Lantern even though he
was dead for a large portion of time
when I was actually reading comic books
so Barry Allen favorite flash so I hope
you guys like this ask emergency Q&A
video I'll be doing them more frequently
now at least one or two times per week
if there's one that you guys
really want to do just let me know in
the comments be sure to subscribe to get
everything to my next Q&A video will be
a Doctor Who Christmas special edition
so you can send me questions about the
regenerations or anything that relates
to Peter Capaldi or anything like that
and that video will post next week
tonight I'm actually posting a
regeneration video that kind of deals
with some of those issues and I'm also
doing a trailer review of the amazing
spider-man 2 trailer that just posts it
you can actually click here to get that
I'll post that later today and then you
can click here to get my last arrow
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys later in high fives